Donald Trump's press secretary, Haley McInerney,
was asked at her Monday press briefing by
reporters whether Donald Trump plans to resume
the Corona virus press briefings, and she
didn't answer the question.
But the answer is obviously no.
And it's a good question to ask because we're
seeing massive corona virus hot spots growing
very rapidly in the United States, mostly
different areas than the early hot spots.
And I'm going to talk about the virus itself
shortly.
But there's a real media story here to understand.
We talk about the bully pulpit of corporate
media.
Much of what is in the national discussion,
the top three stories that are in the national
discussion at any given time are essentially
led by corporate media.
And this is called agenda setting power.
It's not necessarily that corporate media
tells us what to think about any particular
issue, although sometimes they do.
But it's that corporate media tells us what
to think about, what to talk about.
And I'll give you an example.
Remember, kids in cages, the immigration scandal.
It's still going on, but it's rarely, if ever,
in the media, except he mentioned that some
people being held at the border have contracted
coronavirus.
But nothing has fundamentally changed about
that story, which was wall to wall coverage
previously during this administration.
Now it's like it doesn't exist.
Then it was coronavirus.
We have a pandemic.
Daily press briefings, including Donald Trump
and doctors Foushee and Ben Daily updates
down to the specific details about the number
of masks and project air bridge flights from
Mike Pence.
And then the White House signaled we're going
to stop.
Trump wondered aloud about injecting bleach
and isopropyl alcohol to treat Corona virus.
It became clear that the White House didn't
really want more visibility for doctors.
Burks and Foushee talking about the virus.
So the briefing stopped.
And with that, over time, as more and more
states have decided to reopen, some are safely
reopening.
Some are very unsafely reopening.
The topic of the virus itself started to take
a backseat, especially as the George Floyd
killing took place and the massive protests
started.
And now, as we're seeing, the protests are
starting to die down a little bit.
But the big topic has become defund the police
or do not defund the police, depending on
whose perspective you're listening to.
Right wing media saying defunding the police
would be anarchy.
Some on the left furious that Biden does not
want to defund the police, but understand
that nothing materially has changed with Corona
virus.
We'll look at the data, put it up on the screen.
Now, fortunately, as you can see, we've seen
a leveling off and a slow decline in the number
of cases at the national level.
But mostly what we're seeing is the cases
being relocated where we are finding new hotspots.
Understand that at the peak we were finding
25 to 30000 cases a day.
We are still finding 19 to 25000 new cases
every single day.
And the number of active cases, meaning people
who currently have the virus, is still as
high as it's ever been.
And yet Donald Trump barely talks about coronavirus.
His press secretary barely talks about coronavirus.
Right wing media is done with it.
Other than calling it a scam or a conspiracy,
and even corporate media is increasingly talking
about corona virus less and less.
But we have a new political article that points
out not only is the pandemic still very much
a pandemic with no effective treatment, no
vaccine.
We have new hotspots that are setting records
for new cases.
There are parts of the country that are exploding
with virus cases.
And Donald Trump is just silent.
Another massive failure, because Trump, by
not talking about it, makes people think the
threat is over.
Meaning they go out and behave responsibly
and cause even more cases.
And in fact, as we talked about yesterday
on the bonus show, Donald Trump is planning
to restart his huge Mago rallies as part of
his 20-20 reelection campaign in a couple
of weeks.
So I'll give you some really specific examples.
Texas, which started to reopen pretty quickly,
is exploding week to week.
They have more and more cases.
The number of active cases in Texas is higher
today than it has ever been.
Florida, run by Republican Governor Ron DeSantis,
also started to open pretty early.
They were caught lying about numbers as we
previously covered.
And after a small dip sometime in April, which
might have just been then lying, they once
again in Florida are seeing record numbers
of new cases.
Now, I mentioned that the cases are dramatically
shifting from some parts of the country to
others.
This doesn't mean, you know, things aren't
going terribly everywhere.
I am thrilled to say that here in Massachusetts,
at least for now, cases have been very steadily
declining since late a.
Roll the graph I'm showing you.
You'll see a one day spike.
About a week ago.
That's not really a spike.
That was a bunch of presumptive cases from
the three months of Corona virus were all
added in on that day.
But we are looking really good here and I'm
thrilled to see that.
So this is a story not just about the virus
itself, which is still raging with no treatment
or vaccine, but it's a media story as well
about the agenda setting power that corporate
media has.
We said six safe seven weeks ago, Trump strategy
is going to be just start pretending it doesn't
exist.
Start talking about the economy, jobs, reopening,
and a bunch of corporate media has played
along.
Now, in the meantime, things are so bad here
in the United States with Corona virus that
as more and more countries are reopening travel,
the United States is being banned.
I'll give you an example.
Iceland has so dominated the virus that Iceland
decided that on, I believe, its June 15th,
they're going to reopen tourism.
When you get to Iceland, you have to have
a Cauvin test at the airport or quarantine
for 14 days.
People are going to be able to go to Iceland
and start doing tourism if that's what they
want to do.
Except Americans aren't going to be allowed
because things are so out of control here.
Other countries, people are going to be allowed
to start going to Iceland, not Americans,
because it's a disaster.
And I wouldn't be surprised if this continues
as the virus keeps spreading in different
U.S. states.
Other countries are going to be increasingly
controlling it.
Not Brazil, India.
You know, there's places that are Russia that
aren't controlling it, but more and more countries
are going to be allowed to restart travel.
And Americans are going to be banned from
going to other countries because it is so
poorly handled here.
Now, as far as the framing and the propaganda,
expect Trump soon to start arguing that and
TFA and other left wing protesters are responsible
for spreading the virus.
If the numbers keep growing and a lot of these
new hot spots like Florida and Texas.
I would anticipate that Donald Trump will
take the protests as the perfect opportunity
to say it's an fire and lefties that are now
responsible.
If he even mentions it at all and to be clear,
the protests will cause some number of new
cases.
What we're seeing now is reflective of the
situation 10 to 14 days ago.
And that's important to remember.
Be ready for it because it's going to happen.
And don't forget, we're still in the middle
of a pandemic, which some doctors believe
is still in its beginning phases, which
is overwhelming to
think about.